imagine for a moment that anything was
possible imagine for example that the
laws of physics were suddenly replaced
with the laws of the imagination well
that's a very interesting meditation
because it starts out at least for me I
think well if I could have anything what
would I have well what would I like to
have if I could have anything so it
begins modestly I would somehow transfer
the Vatican Library to Versailles and I
would live at Versailles and have access
to the Vatican Library and all other
books and works of art that have ever
existed and I would walk in a garden but
then I start thinking like this and I
say no but the question was what would
it be like if it could be anything why
would you want Versailles
why would you want the Vatican Library
you if you could have anything and you
realize our imagination is completely
constrained by the laws of physics
what would we become if we could become
anything I mean if I could snap my
fingers and you were omnipotent what
would you do the first thing I would do
is I would fly I would just leap about
300 thousand feet in the air and give
the cowboy
but then you would realize you know the
entire universe is now your model you
can cross the galaxy in the wink of an
eye you can journey back to the Big Bang
in the time it takes to think about it
there is no civilization in the history
of the cosmos no work of art no ecstasy
no experience that is beyond you and I
maintain that we would become within
minutes of this transformation
unrecognizable to ourselves because we
are completely defined by our
limitations and and so that's what I
imagine death is its the discovery that
you can be do see think and feel
anything